actress and big me too supporter Alyssa  Milano was a visible presence inside the  committee room at the Kavanagh hearing  she revealed last week that she did not  tell her parents that she had been  sexually assaulted for 30 years we spoke  with her about the me2 movements role in  the Cavanaugh showdown I think women are  scared and I think that the the perfect  storm needed to happen for me to to take  off the way that it did and so many  survivors have come forward and are  standing in solidarity with with dr.  Ford we're not gonna be silenced anymore  we're gonna speak out  it's not a perfect movement there's no  movement that that is people will be  falsely accused of things and that's why  it's so important that we set precedent  for what due process and a fair process  looks like milano told us these  difficult conversations are important  for the me2 movement success